[Music]
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
roof
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
ready
[Music]
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no no no no no
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank
right
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
grace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
right
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
i'm
thank you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
thank
great
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
no
[Applause]
no
hello and welcome to the gamescom
opening night live 2020 pre-show
i'm kyle bossman and this is my hot and
stinky apartment
i realize you probably have a lot of
questions right now like who is this guy
not that important is this the show
no just to be clear this is the pre-show
this is you and me for the next 20
minutes getting excited about opening
night live proper
the big show that one is gonna look nice
that one's got jeff keely that one's got
a budget it's gonna be fancy looking
not like this and then you might be
thinking wait
is the next 20 minutes just this guy
with his headband
talking to me about stuff no it's gonna
be some of that
but most of the show is trailers we have
world premiere trailers right here for
the pre-show
if anything my job is just to smile at
you and fill time in between trailers
in fact we should i think start off with
a trailer we'll talk about opening night
live it's going to be big and fun and
awesome but i feel like the best way to
kick off a pre-show is just to get
right into one our first world premiere
trailer
uh is a game that was just announced
earlier this year at an inside xbox
event
from bandai namco this is scarlet nexus
you have to be prepared for anything
intruders were just detected
[Music]
we have to work together
or the world will be destroyed
we have so many different powers let's
do this
you have your ways of doing things and i
have mine
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
if you're just now joining us this is
the gamescom opening night live 2020
pre-show
that was a trailer for a video game and
not an anime and i'm kyle boss
not important for the next 20 minutes
less than much less than now we are
counting down the minutes
until the big show opening night live in
which you're going to get fresh looks
at fall guys season 2 destiny 2.
call of duty black ops cold war was just
announced yesterday we're already
getting to see more of that tonight lots
of things to see
sidney goodman from ign is going to be
giving out the gamescom awards for best
pc game
best playstation game best xbox game as
well as
talking about some brand new shows from
ign that they are debuting this week at
gamescom
lots of stuff in onl it is going to be a
chunky thick show
but in the meantime for this pre-show it
is time now
for another world premiere on our end
the game next
that we're going to see is called
quantum error and parents
let me warn you now it's time to put the
kids to bed
because it's about to get scary as hell
in here
i don't care if you're in the western
hemisphere and it is the afternoon
put the kids to bed
[Music]
we did it
that artifact you recovered
[Music]
the answer to all our questions
[Music]
we can control them now
use them to travel the stars
humanity's reach will be
infinite
we've got a lot more world exclusive
trailers to go more pre-show to go and
interview with jeff keely next up
we have a car brand synonymous with
racing
and innovation and a key partner of
gamescom for years
ford they're about to exclusively reveal
the first ever car made with gamers for
gamers check it out
ford knows racing in 2019 we brought our
love of racing to gaming
and team godzilla was born and that was
just the beginning
in may we launched project p1 to design
a car
in collaboration with gamers for gaming
this project
was a global first and our designers let
their imagination go wild
so on to our first global announcement
please welcome
our first ever team godzilla project p1
model
[Music]
good
[Music]
and now our second global announcement
you got us so excited
with project p1 that we are now
committing
to make a real-world version of this
groundbreaking car
[Music]
if i didn't have games i think i
guess i would just be writing a lot more
video games and writing are absolutely
my two favorite passions and i just
managed to combine them into a job so i
feel like honestly i probably would have
finished a couple of books
if there was no game what else would i
do i mean i'm a i like tech but
you need to do things on the technology
and so if i can't play things
if i wasn't into gaming yeah it'll be a
lot
of tv watching if there's out there a
universe where i'm not a gamer
then i probably would start to game i
think
i will try something to put some smile
on the face of
everyone i would
watch a lot more movies and read more
books
and get bored
welcome back to the opening night live
pre-show uh
this is only the second year of o l
existing
uh but i think it is safe to say that
this year's will be
unconventional so to tell us what to
expect from
the show this year please welcome jeff
keely
we are now joined by uh jeff keeley
host and executive producer of opening
night live
hi doing jeff i'm doing great kyle how
are you
i'm doing okay uh so
back in april gamescom said we're going
digital this year
when did you start thinking about onl
and how that's going to look
well we knew last year we were going to
do another onl this year because
it was a big success but yeah we had no
idea what format was going to take
normally we were in cologne
this year we're doing it from los
angeles but
actually gamescom came to me and said we
definitely want to
do onl it's a digital event for the
whole world so even if we don't have
something physically in germany we still
want to do this show with you
and i said i was doing summer game fest
and maybe we can bring all these things
together to create
this grand finale uh for the show and
and all summer i was really hoping to
to do a show that was a little bit
bigger than i've been you know
broadcasting
from home here for many months and i
wanted to do something with kind of a
set
and a little bit of spectacle to it and
bring the whole industry together and
that's that's what we're going to do
so is it going to be just as long as a
regular show
yeah we have like two hours of stuff to
show folks um from across the industry
you know like the big stuff uh the
biggest games out there like call of
duty and then a lot
of really uh you know interesting titles
of course we're gonna have
uh some amazing next-gen stuff in the
show and uh and fall guys season two
which
uh has you know become a thing over the
past couple of weeks so it's
it's really fun to have like the big and
the small and the
the the surprises and next-gen all
blended together but yeah it's a
full-blown show two hours
is it going to be just back-to-back
trailers are you going to do some
interviews and demos
you will definitely see trailers you
will see some extended
gameplay demos um of some titles as well
there will be a few interviews with a
couple developers
uh we've got some special guests and one
thing i will say
kind of right out of the gate is that
this is not sort of wall-to-wall
shock and awe announcements of new games
similar to last year at gamescom we have
some really big updates on
games that fans are excited about and
meaningful but you know the kind of big
surprise announcements
we have a few things in the show and and
you know we have lots of great things
planned for the game awards but
similar to last year this is really a
showcase of like big holiday games games
coming next year
that you know about so you know i would
tell people to set their expectations to
be
really meaningful updates on existing
games versus
blowing you away with you know surprise
shock announcements
great jeff i'm personally looking
forward to the show
well me too it's it's been really fun to
build this
but you know even working with our team
it's been challenging um to do things
safely
in the the era of of covid and it's been
it's been meant a lot to me that
gamescom has said we still want to do
this show and i think for all of us in
the industry
we want that big uh showcase so i'm just
really excited to honestly like
leave home do like a a have a set and
you'll see we've got like screens and
lights and it's it's
if we do it right we're gonna hopefully
create that magic moment that
we haven't felt this summer right and a
lot of the events this summer have been
pre-taped and they've been
they've been great and and lots of cool
game info but i really wanted to do
something live with a lot of energy to
it so if
we do things right that's what people
are about to see very cool
good luck with everything thanks kyle
thanks for hosting the pre-show
i'm doing my best
so just so we're on the same page about
what just happened that was basically an
interview with my boss
using questions that i mostly already
know the answers to so
considering all that i think that went
pretty well next up we do have another
world premiere trailer baby
vroom vroom honk honk for dirt 5.
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
it's
[Music]
check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
so you think like a vampire bit a car
and sucked out gas to be continued
it is now time for the part of the
pre-show
that i've been i've been reading your
live comments i see them right now
everybody's blowing up demanding kyle's
10 reasons to be excited for opening
night live
well let's kick it off reason number 10
to be excited for opening night live
2020
feeling excited for next gen again
number nine jeff keeley wardrobe reveal
number eight reason to be excited for
opening night live 2020 destiny trailer
is usually pretty good
number seven it will mean this pre-show
is finally over
number six call of duty black ops cold
war number five reason to be excited for
o
l 2020 shadow drops
number four fall guys season two number
three reason to be excited for onl 2020
actual gameplay from a mysterious
playstation 5 exclusive
number two everything else in my life
sucks right now and the number one
reason to be excited for opening night
live
2020 jeff keeley said it's gonna be good
we have one final world premiere trailer
to show off and this trailer is an
announcement
of a switcher version of a popular game
from 2018 that can only be described as
dinosaursy enjoy
i think that things are going to turn
out differently huh
well the ones before you did too
because they believed that they were in
control
and control well
here's the thing humanity is desperate
for it
we are seduced by it but we never really
possess it
you see life can be tenacious
and stubborn life will not be contained
and what makes us such unique creatures
is knowing the power of what we're up
against
and still believing that we can win
that's it that's all we have for you in
this very pre-show
please be excited for the actual opening
night live in which you'll see some
destiny 2. you'll see fall
guys season 2 you'll see black ops cold
war
that mysterious playstation 5 demo some
things we've probably never heard of
before
i think it's going to be a very good
show i'm personally excited about it
me i should thank you actually for
putting up with my nonsense for the last
20 minutes it is appreciated
but seriously enjoy the show
so what's the plan the time to take
control of our world
when we feel out of place disconnected
and divided there are always
repercussions
do we have what it takes all right i'm
going in
to be heroes what we're doing here could
change things forever
tonight we bring the world together
you're with us now
we celebrate who we are
and what we are i'm with you every step
of the way
the future of gaming welcome to gamescom
opening night live
hello everyone i'm jeff keely and
welcome to gamescom opening night live
2020. now this year gamescom is of
course
a little different than normal and i
hope all of you and your families
are safe and healthy at home in 2020
games have comforted and connected us
more than ever and with the launch of
playstation 5 and xbox series x later
this year
games are only going to get better well
all summer i was hopeful we could get to
this very moment a
big live showcase filled with more than
35 games to kick off gamescom
2020. tonight you'll get a first look at
fall
guys season two and an extended gameplay
demo of ratchet and clank rift apart for
playstation 5.
plus we might have a couple surprises
along the way too
but before we start i want to
acknowledge and thank all the game
developers
marketers and publishers who have worked
under challenging circumstances
to keep us entertained this show is
nothing without them or my production
team
and doing a show at this scale safely is
not easy
especially when all of you at home have
some pretty insane expectations
i hope tonight reminds you why you love
to play games
and with that we're going to move on to
our first game with a game that was just
announced yesterday call of duty black
ops cold war
and joining me is dan von drak from
raven to tell us about the game
and give you an exclusive sneak peek dan
how you doing
good jeff thanks for having me here this
is uh been a dream project for us to
work on from the from nearly the
beginning of development
we knew black ops cold war was going to
be a direct sequel to black ops 1
and we loved the idea of returning to
the pillars
built the black ops franchise deniable
operations conspiracy ground in history
and that shadowy world of paranoia and
we get to mix
all those together drop the player into
the 1980s at the height of the cold war
and it's really something that we know
would feel relevant to today and also
uniquely black ops
well you start playing with black ops
everyone wants to know
characters we saw yesterday in the
reveal trailers you know some familiar
faces so
you know woods mason like break it down
um how does this fit into the black op
cans you said it's a direct sequel so
are we going to see a lot of familiar
faces
yeah part of the fun in making this game
was bringing back the iconic characters
like woods and hudson and mason
and seeing how all those personalities
mix with some of the new characters
so the campaign takes place in 1981 and
we love that we've been able to have so
many connections to the original black
ops and really be that direct sequel to
the game
now one thing that i'm really excited
about this is you're pushing the
storytelling in kind of a new direction
with some branches and some
options about how you play through the
campaign can you maybe walk us through
your thinking there
yeah one of the driving forces from
early in development was to say let's
take this black ops through a ride
and infuse it with some player choice
and some player freedom anything we can
do to give the player a little more
ownership over their experience
so that starts with allowing the player
to create their own character for the
cold war campaign
they can name them and pick a military
background and really
pretend they are that black ops soldier
that they want to be
from there we wanted to take some of our
missions and infuse
optional objectives multiple paths and
some player choice moments
inside some of those missions and it was
fun to find that balance between the
hard driving call of duty action
and these more non-linear experiences
and some inside some of the missions
so with choice comes the player wanting
to feel that
impact so some of those choices earlier
in the game and some towards the end
will actually
shape the ending of the narrative of the
campaign all right so multiple endings
to this game
yeah absolutely absolutely that's that
was one of the big things for us it's
like we love that black ops has always
been willing to take
risks and we all know they did some of
this in black ops 2 and
with our story and with these features
we love playing homage to those early
black ops games
oh yeah i remember the numbers all right
uh well dan
we are excited to see more of it i know
multiplayer reveal is coming in
september but
uh since you got a switch there maybe
you could flip the switch on something
exclusive for us
what are you gonna
yeah absolutely this is really exciting
because this will be the first time
this outside the walls of the
development studio
this is the scene from early in the game
and it's a critical point that
really it shows the narrative of the
world shows this threat that our heroes
are going to be battling
so let's take a look
1943 detailed information from the
manhattan project was stolen from los
alamos by the russian spy known as
perseus 1968
the vietnam war vietcong soldiers
orchestrated by perseus
attempted to steal an american-made
nuclear bomb from a u.s
fire base five days ago
while on a mission we acquired intel
that perseus is in play again
and planning an attack on the west
purses the cia's analysts consider him
to be the single
largest threat to the free world
mr hudson we're all aware of perseus
we're also aware he's more myth than
fact i mean
personally i think he's nothing more
than the russian boogeyman general hague
allow me to introduce the man i suited
the responder
cia clandestine special officer russell
adler
he's one of the few people even come
close to capturing
uh mr adler why should we take this
perseus threat seriously you don't have
to sir
yeah but then a lot of innocent people
are going to die why do you say that
sir every time perseus has come into
play it shifted the balance of the cold
war
after 13 years of silence if he's active
something big is gonna happen
something that will affect the free
world
[Music]
mr president sir mr president mr
president this is
jason hudson and russell i know their
names
who do you think approve their last
mission
is the threat real yes sir we believe it
is
can you stop perseus we can sir i've
already submitted the requisition for my
team
sir their requests are highly irregular
most likely illegal if the press gets
old what the hell are you talking about
you know who we are every mission we go
on is illegal
sergeant woods plausible deniability is
the backbone of our work
now we're talking about preventing an
attack on the free men and women of the
world
give mr adler whatever he wants
gentlemen
you've been given an important task
protecting our very way of life from a
great evil
there is no higher duty there is no
higher honor
and while few people will know of your
struggles
rest assured the entire free world
will benefit i know you won't fail us
tonight we have some new game
announcements for you guys as well
including this one a new next-gen
narrative action adventure game from
reflector entertainment in montreal
it's called unknown nine the game tells
the story of haruna a woman raised on
the streets of india
and haunted by visions of her own death
haruna struggles to understand her
mysterious innate abilities to
manipulate the unseen
check out this first look
i found you
[Music]
i hear them
[Music]
i hear them calling
[Music]
from
all right let's get to the gameplay one
of this year's biggest games has been
doom eternal tonight we've got an
exclusive first look
at the campaign expansion called the
ancient gods part one
check this out
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
please proceed with control assertive
aggression
oh
again
2020 marks the 25th anniversary of a
legendary game studio
bioware tonight casey hudson and the
team wanted to give everyone around the
world
a little taste of what's next casey
over to you hey jeff it's great to see
you again
you know six years ago we were on the
stage with you at the 2014 game awards
accepting the game of the year for
dragon age inquisition
and since then we've been imagining new
ways to use next generation technology
to bring the world and characters of
dragon age to life
we're still in early production but we
thought it was time to give you the very
first look
at how bioware's passionate team of
developers are crafting this very
special game
i've been a borrower for a really long
time so i've got to see it grow up and
turn from
from a company of 35 people to a company
of more than 300 people
there's amazing people in the industry
there's amazing stories to be told with
other
people i love that character so much
we're very experimental here at bioware
so we're always coming up with new stuff
we're always trying to improve
innovate and bring new characters to
life for players and fans to enjoy
the world of dragon age really has got
it all
it's got frontier stories it's got
mystery
it's got hard-boiled detective stories
and of course it's all wrapped up in
kind of a fantasy setting
you really feel like you're the hero in
the dragon age world and
you're saving people dragon age to me
is a wonderful world to play in
i am really excited about the future of
dragon age
[Music]
this is an original world original flora
original wildlife original architecture
that makes it fun to explore and
discover
in the next dragon age we get an
opportunity to to see new things new
places
and interact with people who lived and
grew up in these spaces as well
for the game we're working on now we
want to tell a story what happens when
you don't have power
what happens when the people in charge
aren't willing to address the issues
the things that you can expect in the
next installment are going to be stories
that focus on the people around you
and the friends and family you make
[Music]
something we'll be able to look forward
to in dragon age
is a really close relationship with game
characters who really become real for
you
we want characters to either be loved or
hated one of the best examples of that
is soulless
half the community wants to kill him
half the people want to marry him then
another part want to do both
they call me the dread wolf
what will they call you when this is
over
bioware and ea has been one of the
forerunners in using motion magic
technology
and that makes it way more realistic
when you're looking at the characters
and the way they walk
and move and interact in the world
players wanting that suspension of
disbelief that this
wonderful collection of digital pixels
is actually a living breathing soul no
no no
it's okay that's the good kind of rumble
i actually designed bosses i help with
the creature design team as well so i do
all like the big threats that you have
to go up against
nobody dies on my watch for the wardens
choice is a big part of what dragon age
is as a franchise
the decisions you make can affect change
in the world decision
making can mean that a party member
lives or a party member
dies and it means owning your outcome
and reactivity to
the choices that you do make i just love
the possibilities that dragon age offers
us
and i'm excited to explore a lot more of
them
to me that potential is what gets you up
in the morning
it's a fantastic opportunity
every time
next up it's time for something special
great scott i think there's a serious
miscalculation wow wait you're uh what
what's his name back to the future i'm
emil brown
doctor of physics medicine and certainly
not that quack from rick and morty
yeah we know who you are but what are
you doing here i did come back from the
future to this
precise moment on august 27 2020
because it's imperative we launched
certain simulator 2 right now
and what exactly do you have to do with
surgeon simulator
during the mid 20th century some friends
of mine from an arshar
university invented a state-of-the-art
medical training facility otherwise
known
as the surgeon simulator training
program
now 70 years later we've digitized the
experience
it's unbelievable you can access the
program
through your computer and then be
medically trained
from the comfort of your keyboard and
it's available as
a great scott
this very moment tonight
i want a world premiere a few examples
of some of the incredibly
successful test subjects who have
already completed
the course so you're saying a world
premiere will save our future
only time will tell and speaking of time
i'm off to another world premiere
avengers 26
the return of the son of thanos opening
2077 and with that i leave you the fade
of the human race
in your hands just make sure you play
search principles too
doctor's orders
[Applause]
[Music]
where does this person go
he looks good now grab the good arm and
bring it in here
we're dying he's dying
[Music]
that's not right my fingers slipped
jesus christ put it back ugh
doc brown introducing jacksepticeye
playing surgeon simulator only
on opening night live all right well if
you thought that crossover was kind of
crazy
wait until you get a load of this next
game announcement that
i don't think anyone probably saw coming
check this out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
tonight is just the start of gamescom
2020 over the next three days there are
more streams from ign and web media
with in-depth looks at games a digital
cosplay contest and some special new
shows
just for gamescom your portal for all
things gamescom this year is gamescom
now which you can check out at
gamescom.global
now one game you'll hear more about
later on ign's post show is
this one a return of two classic
characters
that i love check this out
[Music]
in a world gone strange
[Music]
one elite force stands against the
darkness
but even they could use some help here
slip on this little beauty for a fact
[Music]
sam i blind oh hello
yes
[Music]
[Music]
the return of sam and max yes all right
and now it's time to say hello to my
wonderful co-host for onl
from ign please say hello to sydney
goodman
thank you jeff what's up everyone i'm
sydney goodman and i am
thrilled to be here gamescom is always
such a fun event and throughout the show
tonight i'll be telling you about all
the different ways that ign is involved
in this year's festivities
but first i have an award to announce
the winner of
best nintendo switch game is little
nightmares 2
huge congratulations like i said ign is
going to be here for all of gamescom
with great shows such as gamescom studio
where you can find me and my co-hosts
for all day long games content
interviews dev talks and more
plus we have gamescom awesome indies the
show with
and for indie developers that premieres
saturday august 29th
at 7 p.m central european time so be
sure to tune in for more announcements
and special guests and now
let's go back to jeff for our next big
world premiere
awesome thank you so much sid we are so
excited to see what's in the uh the game
com studio and also awesome indies and
i'm going to be on the daily show
tomorrow so looking forward to that
all right well on to our next game in
the next world of warcraft expansion
players will journey beyond the mortal
world of azeroth to a place where no
living soul has set foot before
the shadow lands the afterlife of an
entire warcraft universe
the infinite realms of the shadow lands
are watched over by different factions
known as covenants
each holding dominion over a different
aspect of the afterlife
and depending on how someone lived their
mortal life they may end up as part of
one of these covenants when they cross
over into the shadow lands
today we're excited to give you a closer
look at the noble and pure
kirian covenant from the realm of
bastion who are charged with carrying
the souls of the dead
into the beyond so sit back and get
ready for the world premiere of bastion
the first in blizzard entertainment's
new four-part series of animated shorts
called afterlives enjoy
ugh
[Laughter]
[Music]
light save my soul
[Music]
uther where
where am i welcome
to bastian
[Music]
you led a truly selfless life
and for that you have been chosen
chosen to shed your mortal burdens
and join the ranks of the ascended
serving to ferry the souls of the dead
unto the shadowlands i serve
the light and my work is not
done there is an evil that must be
there is no evil here the darkness was
sealed within the maw
long ago you're wrong he destroyed my
home murdered my people and my
king he must be punished you are an
aspirant now
you must accept your new purpose
and purge yourself of this desire for
vengeance
what i desire is
justice
davos why are you training this soul
it is beneath your station as a paragon
he cannot let go he continues to demand
retribution for his death and this
concerns you
many souls take eons to ascend yes
but this one seems broken thanios
unlike any soul i have seen i have begun
to wonder whether he was deemed worthy
of
bastion
[Music]
i would not let the arkhan hear such a
thought
in time he will forget
trust our ways trust
the path
devos how long
must we train until you are ready to
ascend
and what is keeping me from ascension
nothing but the memory of your mortal
life
how can i forget when i can still
feel his blade
your soul is wounded
who did this to you he was
my student he betrayed us
[Music]
all
the runes on his blade were unmistakable
this dark agent runs free on a mortal
world
with the power of the maw itself in hand
our realm is imperiled impossible
the maw is inescapable you must return
to the path
if he had purged his life we never would
have known
of this calamity the path is
flawed enough the order of the shadow
lands depends
on the execution of our eternal charge
you will abandon this course
as you command
the time of your ascension has come
i thought i was not ready
do you wish to see him punished
i do then prepare yourself
[Music]
the moment he falls
we will claim him
i see
only darkness
before me
[Music]
now cast him into the maw
return him to the darkness he served
his eternal suffering
awaits
he was my student
remember what he
[Music]
and take your vengeance
not vengeance
justice
[Music]
[Applause]
all right hope you guys enjoyed that
exclusive look at bastian now we know
many of you can't wait to experience
shadowlands
and our friends at blizzard want you to
know the wait
is almost over
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
october 27th it is official we have so
much more opening night live still to go
for you ratchet and clank playstation
5. uh much more stay tuned all right but
now it's time for the announcement of a
new universe that is coming to gaming
for the first time
with a project from a canadian studio
check this out
they have returned they corrupted
divided conquered
until finally the gates
of the celestial realm were thrown
open our last
remaining hope the stormcast eternals
vengeance made manifest
unbound unbroken
we will take back while the dead have
[Music]
ravaged
now you guys may remember back in june i
had some masked
fun with my buddy crash bandicoot
announcing crash for it's about time
with the game coming in october crash of
course had to come back for opening
night live so let's bring him out
everybody crash bandicoot
what he's where
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
poor crash apparently didn't get the
memo about gamescom but to tell us more
about what we just saw i'm joined by lou
studdard from toys for bob
uh lou what did we see there with uh
crash in the games combat
uh apparently you saw him wandering
around cologne but uh
what he was hinting at was kind of our
reveal of what we call
flashback tapes which are a brand new
style of level that we are announcing
here today
okay so uh how do these flashback levels
kind of play into the overall
crash foreign narrative yeah so the way
that the the flashback tape levels work
is that
they are kind of a peak back in time to
the 90s
when neocortex was actually testing on
crash and coco before the events of
crash bandicoot 1.
and they're kind of these devious puzzle
rooms that we've made
and they're really hard and they're
really awesome
and they're super creative and we can't
wait to get people's hands on them
yeah i know i i got to play a demo of
this a few weeks ago and that was a
challenge so i can't imagine
um how nefarious these are um how are
they gonna be sort of integrated into
the game are they
they optional like offshoot stuff or how
do you how do you get to them sure
so players actually have to collect the
flashback tapes
in the levels themselves uh they're an
object that they can pick up
and to actually pick them up they have
to reach them in the level without dying
it's
kind of our homage to the death routes
from the original trilogy so players
have to
reach these objects in the level pick
them up and then once they get them
they'll get access
to these unique levels so beyond the
pure
challenge uh what other funds how are
these fun for players to kind of
experience what do they get to do on
them
sure so one of the things that we did
was we actually used these as
like i said puzzle rooms really kind of
fun nefarious devious ways for crash to
really express
that pure platforming kind of uh aspect
of gameplay that we know and love about
the franchise but then
narratively for us it was really cool to
layer in
kind of a unique perspective to the
franchise this is the moment when
cortex is really excited about the
prospect of
crash being on his team because crash
was originally
created by cortex and so this is a weird
point in time that's never really been
explored in the games before
awesome all right well crash 4 it's
about time looks
phenomenal lou we cannot wait to check
it out uh in october thanks for joining
us
yeah thanks for having me awesome all
right well we will be right back
after this for more gamescom opening
night live
i have become terror
the unseen predator
a rupture that obliterates without
warning
alone the hordes of enoch will fall
before me
but together this entire planet
will fear us
the anomaly alters us each in our own
ways yet we are drawn
down the same road into the dark heart
of creation
[Music]
we will find the source whatever it
holds
whatever it takes
so
[Music]
welcome to the hyperscape enter a
contender
yes
time to party
welcome to necromunda i can see you're
new here
let me get you up to speed the
underhives named well
a sprawl of humanity suffering away like
ants
deep underground where we ain't causing
trouble but are rich boys and girls
no matter how loud we are and do we ever
make some noise
every all lock says they could shoot the
tail off a lash work
and they'd splash your head from 20
paces for saying they couldn't
i don't want to say immortal but when
their armor
blood skin and will are of iron it's a
potent combo
why would someone like you want to know
about an all-female gang
of psychopaths drug dealers killers
cloners and oh makes sense
and asha will cut you up just for the
fun of it
goliaths are big that's
it anything smaller than them doesn't
deserve to live
and they're just as happy filling you
with lead as they are smashing you to
pieces with a powerball
now mixing that whole pot together in a
place like this
you can imagine what happens chaos
gang warfare for wealth for power
hell sometimes just for fun so
think you're ready necromunda under high
fours comes to playstation 4 xbox one
and pc on september 8th
[Music]
is
[Music]
i envision the future gaming to be quite
bright
and quite online the next generation of
consoles will clearly allow
aaa and indie developers to build more
creative driven
games that i hope will cover more
diverse subjects
i want to play all kinds of stories
about people and places both real
and imagined i want comedy games i want
autobiographical games i
really want to see what people can do
with the media profuse games
um
us
[Music]
you know one of the things i love about
opening night is that we can show you
the biggest games in the industry and
also
smaller titles that should be on your
radar so pay attention to this next game
it comes from a team of two
in sweden tuxedo labs over the past
three years developer dennis gustafson
has built his own game engine to realize
his vision
for a fully destructible game world what
he's building has absolutely blown me
away
so i asked dennis to prepare a special
trailer just for tonight
i hope you're equally inspired by the
ideas in this next game definitely one
to watch
tear down
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
last year at opening night live we
announced little nightmares to
to the world well the team at tarsier
studios hasn't shown anything
since but that changes right now here is
a first look at the gameplay
of little nightmares 2 which is coming
next february
with more to come throughout the week at
gamescom including a live demo
on gamescom studio tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
nice all right thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm wwe hall of famer jerry the king
lawler and i'm reuniting with my old
buddy mauro ronaldo
to bring you all the over-the-top action
in wwe 2k
battleground mamma mia
this is great this arcade style video
game
is over the top outrageous with over 70
wwe superstars and legends
crawling it out like never before
oh no hold on to your 2k morrow look out
below
wwe is l-i-t
you know i'm a little more old-school
than morrow so i can't wait to see these
wwe legends
teach these kids a thing or two and you
know what here's a closer look
at the insane action
party rolling with another matchup oh
look out mauro the undertaker has risen
and finn balor is about to be taken for
his last ride
mia what a move finish him oh no
he just hit the snooze button how do you
lose like that what's the matter with
you legends
this is just an example of the
pandemonium that you're going to
experience
when you head to the battlegrounds
that's a big toy hammer oh
i can't believe my eyes seth rollins
delivers the stop
what a night what a night this is the
greatest thing i've ever seen
pre-order wwe 2k battlegrounds today
and brawl without limits
[Music]
mamma mia oh sorry moro i know that's
your line
hello again i have even more awards to
announce so let's get
right down to it the winner of best
action adventure game
is watchdogs legion the city needs a
resistance
and it starts with you what do you say
[Music]
the winner of the best action game is
star wars
[Music]
squadrons
the winner of best multiplayer game is
operation tango
operation tango it takes two to save the
world
[Music]
i used to be an explorer the winner of
best indie game is curious expedition 2.
did not believe what i had witnessed
it was time for the world to learn
my name congratulations to all the
winners
as we mentioned ign will be here for all
of gamescom with great shows and new
ways for you to get all your gaming news
check it out gamescom 2020 is the heart
of gaming and you can keep to the beat
right here on ign
we've turned the single biggest show and
gaming into five gamescom now
is your virtual show floor with up to
the second live coverage
gamescom daily show gamescom's first
ever late night talk show
our gamescom awesome indie show the
freshest deep cuts in indie gaming
and finally the gamescom best of show
including
the gamescom award gamescom 2020 is
available on ign and wherever you stream
gamescom now
and now it is time to talk about that
best action game winner star wars
squadrons this is a new immersive space
combat game
from motive studios that delivers the
ultimate star wars pilot fantasy
we've missed those in squadrons you'll
suit up and fly for both the new
republic and the galactic empire
across intense 5v5 multiplayer battles
as well as an all-new authentic
single-player story set after the events
of star wars episode 6
return of the jedi today we'll get a
glimpse of what squadron's story has to
offer
by taking a brief look at one of the
single-player missions featuring some
light narration
by the motive team let's check it out
we all choose our path light or dark
freedom or destruction the empire chose
to destroy alderaan in order to spread
fear
and douse the fires of rebellion but the
heroic pilots of the rebel alliance have
chosen to keep fighting
to show the empire that we are not
afraid
it was their bravery that ended
palpatine's reign and brought about our
new republic
however the empire lives on shattered
though it may be
as i speak imperial forces are edging
toward the bormia sector
hoping to end our new republic before we
find our footing
as their empire collapses they try to
tighten their grip
but the galaxy is changing and you can
be a part of it
with the help of brave and daring pilots
this war can end
make a choice fly with the new republic
change our galaxy for the better
hi i'm suzanne hunka narrative producer
on star wars squadrons
our single-player story is one of daring
pilots and deep-seated rivalries
take titan squadron hunt down this
starhawk
and eliminate it gladly add more sloane
over the course of the story you'll fly
as two pilots on opposite sides of the
war
and like all modes in star wars
squadrons you'll have the option to
experience
every mission fully immersed in vr right
antilles
rogue squadron i hear you're the reason
i was able to finally get a com through
today we're giving you a glimpse of an
early imperial mission
behind enemy lines one of our spies
agent thorne has discovered vital
intelligence on project starhawk
your mission is to extract her from an
orbital outpost above hosni and prime
behind enemy lines you'll have to
eliminate perimeter defenses
the outpost is defenseless when you've
secured the area you will escort the
gladius to the outpost
and our extraction team will acquire
agent thorne
once thorn is secure reach your gozanti
cruisers and return to the overseer
cover our escape and escort us to the
jump point we have republic corvettes
inbound
ladies change course and keep major
thorns safe
titan three take out those fighters
understood
i'll handle it
[Music]
each mission will immerse you into the
escalating conflict between the new
republic
and a shattered empire debrief with your
squadmates between missions
you're our new wingmaid customize and
master all eight starfighters and join
the galaxy's finest
i need you focused and ready to go
[Music]
from bombing runs at the nadiri
dockyards
to setting a trap in the xavian abyss
the story of these rival squadrons will
push the war to the brink
and define the galaxy for years to come
i look forward to seeing you in combat
october 2nd
that is not all ea has to share from a
galaxy far
far away today at star wars galaxy edge
you can enter the world of batu
where you can visit oga's cantina or
jump into the millennium falcon on a run
to smugglers cove it was this incredible
adventure at disneyland resort and walt
disney world resort that inspired
the sims latest game pack check this out
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
up
yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
there is even more star wars to come
later in the show
lego star wars the skywalker saga is up
and as we move into our second hour
we've got fall guys season two still to
come the reveal of that which i can't
wait for you guys to see
and of course a gameplay demo of ratchet
and clank rift apart for playstation 5.
but right now
you might remember this next game from
annapurna interactive from last year's
microsoft e3 event
and today i'm excited to share a new
announcement from the team
this interactive thriller about a man
stuck in a time loop
is one of this year's most intriguing
indie titles and now
they've added an absolutely all-star
cast to the game here's a whole new look
at 12 minutes
all right close your eyes i want you to
think of
a flower look at its contours its curves
now i want you to imagine it changing
think of that bud an open
look at it as a whole then silently
repeat these phrases
may you be free from suffering may you
be
free from fear may you know
peace and joy
[Music]
that's gonna be a really special indie
game so glad to announce that here on
the show
uh now last year at the game awards we
announced godfall
a new looter shooter coming to
playstation 5 and pc from counter play
tonight we've got a quick sneak peek of
one of the new valor plates with more
footage coming
as part of gamescom 2020. check this out
[Music]
we have much more o l to come exclusive
looks at lego star wars the skywalker
saga
fall guys season two
wait until you see what the media tonic
guys are up to and so much more but
first
i'm sure you saw that earlier this week
heart of deimos warframe's newest
expansion was released on pc xbox and
ps4
and today it's also on switch all
platforms
here's a look at the heart of deimos
expand explore
tear the veil assembled
new territory to our sovereign ways
but that was what it wanted to
it raged unchecked through
metal bone
flesh
life we are
infested with
[Applause]
[Music]
now the gateway is failing
the jars close
the final heartbeat
approaches
have you tried turning it off and on
again
but before we fall
we shall scream
there is one who will hear
the heart of james
so many people have been discovering or
rediscovering video games
during lockdown whether it be older
people or
bored teenagers or middle-aged parents
who suddenly find
they have to do something together with
their kids
and i think i've given out more advice
about video games in 2020 than
any other time ever and as a result it's
more important than ever that we keep
making different interesting things for
folk to play
i hope everybody gets healthy and safely
through this
corona virus time
care about other people and
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first mistake don't come up missing just
checking the list
i'm always aware of your current
position i just hold up to the perfect
condition
coming alive
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys we're back officially
into hour two we've got an
hour more of great stuff to show you
destiny two beyond light staces you're
gonna see a brand new look at that
fall guys season 2 and ratchet and clank
for playstation 5 and
so much more across the next hour
opening night live continues and it just
is the start of gamescom
2020 but right now on september 25th
mafia definitive edition launches a
comprehensive built from the ground up
remake of the original mafia
tonight we've got the exclusive debut of
the next trailer called a life of reward
too big to ignore
which deals with tommy's induction into
the salieri crime family
check this out
all these guys in this room
they're here because they have the only
thing that matters to me
the only thing that should matter to any
of us
you know what that is tommy they're
loyal
that's right
one day you're busting your back doing
an honest day's work in a city that's
been trying to scrape you off its heels
since the day you stepped off the boat
and the next your stuff in your pockets
full of salieri's dirty money
go get them tommy teach these boys a
lesson
break every bone in their bodies
you want me to become one of those wall
street boys don't sass me tommy
i'm trying to teach you the ropes so you
don't get strangled by them
now you stay straight with me you're
going to be living the high lifetime
you abuse my trust don salieri
you won't ever need to worry about me
okay then
welcome to the family
next we're going to introduce you to a
turn-based multiplayer strategy fps
from a team in montreal canada lemnis
gate is coming in early 2021 and has a
unique mechanic
built around a 25 second time loop
check this out
[Music]
[Music]
next spring get ready to experience
memorable moments and non-stop
action from all nine star wars films in
lego star wars the skywalker saga the
entire series has been reimagined
with new fun-filled lego humor and now
we've got your first look
at the gameplay trailer
i want to learn the ways of the force
and become a jedi like my father
[Applause]
the force is unusually strong with him
that much is clear
twisting by the dark side
young skywalker has become
[Music]
there is another
and from their assistance your sister
leia sent me
we need your help
[Music]
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not him
[Music]
[Music]
i am a jedi like my father before me
so be it jedi
[Music]
man lego star wars looks so fun coming
to next gen as well
all right we'll be right back with more
world premieres from huge new games like
ratchet and clank
rift apart medal of honor above and
beyond and destiny 2. but before that
here's a look at a game that is
launching tonight on nintendo switch and
steam
it's called struggling from frontier a
fun physics-based platformer where up to
two players
control troy our fleshy hero check this
out and remember you can play this
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
where are we we're near little hope
did you hear that what's more proof is
needed
that the devil walks among us in little
hole
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
i gotta say the game that i've given the
most hours to that i love going back to
is assassin's creed odyssey
not to say since origins came out this
new reboot of the assassin's creed
uh so to speak that was my first time
getting into it and i have put
almost 400 hours into assassin's creed
odyssey at the moment i enjoy to play
fall guys with my friends it's very
funny
easy to learn but hard to master i have
a few games that i binge play
um games that i return to every year uh
halo the entire master chief collection
is really a big one for me where that's
concerned
but i also still just casually binge
animal crossing and i've been doing that
basically all year
i haven't put down animal crossing since
i downloaded it i find
the daily repetitive rhythm so soothing
and predictable
although much like my house my island is
still a complete tip
up next we have the award for best
microsoft xbox game
and the winner is tell me why
congratulations to donut entertainment
well after a big day of gamescom events
and announcements you'll be happy to
know that ign is going to help you
digest
all that info with gamescom daily show
where you can get all the daily
highlights and a late night show
experience
from gamers for gamers back to you jeff
thank you very much sid uh and by the
way congratulations to
dontnod for uh tell me why a really
important game that
is out now that you can play um on xbox
xbox and game pass
and as we know there's a lot going on in
the world and that goes beyond the
pandemic
between social conflicts we're seeing in
the news and acts of nature
we can see how vulnerable we as people
can sometimes be
and now i think it's as important time
as ever to remember
to come together and support one another
we are a global gaming community there
are millions of people watching tonight
and i know we're all here
because we love games and we know that
games are
good in the world and can bring us
together and i think we've all felt that
in
2020 so i think that's really important
to remember amongst all the games and
trailers
all right well one game one one way as a
community we can come together to do
some good
is the gamescom forest gamescom has
launched a reforestation project by
planting a gamescom forest together with
the community
gamers worldwide can go to
gamescom.global and donate to plant more
trees
so let's plant a forest together all
right well now we're going to move on to
another game and this one was announced
back in may
chorus is a dark space combat shooter
where players take control of nara on a
quest to destroy
the dark cult that created her featuring
rich ray traced 4k
60 fps environments on next-gen hardware
here is the first look at gameplay from
chorus
you have broken my heart
for your betrayal you
will be broken
so
[Music]
so
how many crowns have you won if one game
has defined the summer of 2020
it absolutely is fall guys from
mediatonic in london and devolver
this game is setting records and putting
a much needed smile on
everyone's face fall guys i think
represents
our industry at its absolute best well
soon the fall guys experience will
evolve with season two
there's a lot of new stuff coming and
tonight
mediatonic is about to give you an
exclusive sneak peek
at what's next get ready i think the
internet
is about to freak out here it is fall
guys
season two
hey i'm joe i'm the lead game designer
on four guys ultimate knockout and i
just wanted to reach out and say thank
you to everyone who's been playing and
enjoying their game so far
as a team we've been looking at all the
fan arts the memes and the montages that
people have been posting online
and the response to the game has really
blown us away today we just wanted to
give everyone their first sneak peek at
the rounds and the costumes that they
can be enjoying as part of 4 guys season
[Music]
[Applause]
2.
in season two you'll be dressing your
full guy as a medieval hero
and competing across brand new rounds
inspired by epic quests from the middle
ages
traverse giant drawbridges dodge
swinging axes and scale movable seed
ramps in the quest for ultimate
game show glory
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed the sneak peek of
full guide season two we're still adding
the finishing touches to development but
if you want to stay up to date then
pool guys game on twitter is where you
want to be see you on the start line
[Applause]
[Music]
my father has colorado in the palm of
his hand
and he's afraid to close his fist
[Music]
i am not
[Music]
liberty's got more brains and cunning
than both her brothers put together
she's the only one who could actually
run colorado she's already tried once
vic's a depraved child and vows a brain
without a spine
the years my father wasted grooming them
for glory
when i was right there
[Music]
go back to arizona rangers and i'll
pretend none of this happened
stay and you die alone
[Music]
i really haven't found any new
appreciation for gaming at this time
because my
appreciation for gaming before
you get to travel all over the world in
games which is something i've always
taken for granted
at the moment i'm playing go sushima and
you know i kind of prefer it to the real
japan just because i've heard that in
real life
they don't let you run around with
taiwanese i appreciate games
a lot more than films music or whatever
and it's just fine
uh for me to to have the time to play
with friends
or even with my family and to have a lot
of fun
i've been mostly at home with small
children and gaming is the only thing
that i get to do for myself
anymore i find it's not only an escape
it's also a way to challenge my brain
gaming is becoming clearly more
important for a lot of people
you know play is a natural instinct and
from animal crossing to the last of us
part two or
ori yes yes it's definitely an
incredible time now
to be a gamer yes
hey everyone i'm vince sampela head of
respawn entertainment
when we set out to create medal of honor
above and beyond we knew we wanted to
bring the series back to its roots
the medal of honor franchise is known
for its powerful and exciting single
player stories
that put the player in the boots of a
soldier who was there it's a series that
is grounded in history which tells
emotionally authentic stories
peter hirschman who directed the
original medal of honor in 1999
is back at the helm of this project
you'll hear more from him in just a bit
peter and i actually worked together on
medal of honor allied assault in 2002
and i'm really happy he's joined us to
respond to craft a completely new
experience in vr
the team is creating a riveting and
emotional journey through world war ii
like you've never seen her played
it weaves in the personal stories of the
veterans and survivors of the war
through powerful interviews that help
set the stage for what players will
experience
it's more than just a game we could not
be more excited to show the world
the next look at medal of honor above
and beyond and the game's action-packed
story
let's take a look
i know this is the first time some of
you will see combat
i know you're scared let me be clear
with all of you
i'm scared too
welcome to france gentlemen i lead the
local resistance cell
something big is happening inside
gestapo headquarters
and we don't know what it is we're gonna
have to improvise here
members of the resistance are perhaps
the bravest
people fighting in this war
but you really should stop there is no
future in it sorry to interrupt
[Music]
lieutenant
it'll be a wild ride but we'll get you
there
jet fighters brace yourselves
like i said boom
there are things as people
i'm willing to sacrifice myself for
[Music]
somehow this motley crew has been tasked
with saving civilization
god help us all
thank you so much vince that looks
incredible and now we're here with
respawn entertainment's peter hirschman
game director on medal of honor above
and beyond to talk more about their new
vr experience uh peter i got to say the
trailer
really grabbed me such an incredible
story that you're telling to
tell us a bit about this single-player
experience what can we expect
well jeff thank you for having us on the
show the i'm representing a whole team
back at respawn that's been working
really hard on this and it's
so exciting to premiere the trailer uh
with you
uh metal uh going back to its roots was
always about putting
uh the player in the boots of a soldier
fighting in world war ii um and with vr
we're able to do that
in almost a literal way it's it's
definitely the most immersive experience
most immersive combat experience i've
ever been able to work on
um and the story follows uh you as a
player being recruited
into the office of strategic services
um commonly known as the oss uh and
their mission was sabotage espionage
search and rescue everything uh in
between uh you name it they did it
um and they're known by a different set
of initials uh now the the cia
but during world war ii uh they sent
operatives
all over europe deep behind enemy lines
uh and that allows us to tell a story
where you get to go to these places and
locations and
participate in events that really helped
shape the outcome of the work one of the
things i love about the trailer is you
can tell there's a lot of
interactivity in the environment
emerging
story it seems gamepl it's all kind of
through a first person perspective but
there are some story sequences how do
you tell the story
oh well we shot we shot over 120 pages
or div
um you know which is more than some
feature films
we had a huge international cast of
phenomenal actors
uh and it was fantastic and the story
follows a
a classic three three act structure um
act one is working with the french
resistance getting ready for
the invasion uh act two is d-day itself
and the fight
uh to get to berlin uh and then the
third act is dealing with the nazi
secret weapon program
which involved things like the 262 uh
jet and the v2 rocket and things that
could have really turned the tide
of the war if if we hadn't stopped them
um so you get to
go on this this journey you know this
story
um and the story is shot all
from your perspective because it's vr
your head
is the camera we don't have cut scenes
we don't have edits
everything everything revolves around
your perspective so you experience this
story
completely in first person as as if you
are there
um so it creates a much more intimate
and and uh
emotional connection with the characters
and the things going on around you
uh it it was an incredible way to shoot
one of our animators stood in for the
the player throughout uh throughout the
three weeks that we're on stage
and all the actors are are always
reacting and talking to you directly and
in vr it's such a powerful thing it's
all about building that
emotional connection and just makes the
experience fall
more authentic well you and vince
i know this this series is really close
to your heart and
uh i'm like wow there's there's so much
there to experience it looks really
rich and detailed obviously authentic as
well you know paying tribute
um to everyone that uh was involved in
in the war
i i wanted to ask you also about
multiplayer which is something that
respawn is really
known for and you've had a great single
player experience but i hear
you might also be doing mp2 oh
well yeah i mean the thing about vr is
that
you know i've spent so much i mean we
know each other a long time
you know you know your career trying to
map natural human movements to uh to a
controller and just
figuring out like making feel good and
one of the hardest ones is is leaning
and in vr you know how you duck you just
duck and and how you lean in vr you you
just lean
and so the ability to lean around a
corner just kind of peek around the
corner and see where the bad guy is
is just it heightens the tension so much
it makes it
it makes it feel all the more real and
when you put that into a multiplayer
experience
it just raises it to a whole nother
level so we are shipping
in addition to the campaign we are
shipping a full suite of vr modes
uh including a few that you can only do
in vr and we're really excited about
uh people playing those uh um you know
after it comes out wow well definitely a
full-blown vr experience i gotta say i'm
really
excited to put the headset on and try
this and it's coming out
later this year right coming out holiday
so
uh yeah fasten your seat belts uh we're
we are so excited to to bring it to
players we've been working on a long
time like like you mentioned it's a
passion project for
for vince and i and everyone at respawn
um it's it's uh
it's a wonderful full circle uh
experience for a lot of us that got our
started our careers working on those
original set going back first one and
and and allied assault and now to be
able to bring above and beyond
uh to a whole new generation is is one
of the most exciting things we've been
involved with
awesome thank you so much peter opening
night live we'll be right back and in
the meantime here's a look at a new game
that is launching
tonight
the world was broken fractured
by the magic the vow keepers said they
would protect us from
spellstorms still rage across the ruins
of the hololands
this is proof they said
it isn't safe it can't be controlled
magic cannot be used
[Music]
but i am a battle mage
[Music]
i have broken my vow
and now i fight to break free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
do
[Music]
so many great games in xbox game pass
and many of tonight's games are in it as
well
uh every year at gamescom we like to
highlight some incredible games made in
germany and tonight
we have a special announcement about one
of the most legendary german games of
all time created by factor five enjoyed
factor five was so far ahead of the
curve and each of their games pushed
game technology as far as possible
i'd say they're one of the greatest
indie developers of all time
foreign
[Music]
this was the first game that allowed me
to completely fulfill my musical vision
it defined my career and the fans have
been there ever since
to this day it's one of my proudest
works
[Music]
in june bungie revealed a new era of
destiny 2 that starts on november 10th
with beyond light
for the first time ever guardians will
add a new elemental power to their
arsenal
the dark power of stasis with stasis
players will take on the powers of
darkness to control and dominate the
battle
here's an all-new look at stasis from
destiny 2
beyond light
the floodgates are open the darkness
is here
as you step away from the light
we need only look inward focus your
power
let it grow our fight
is far from over
[Music]
[Music]
let them come this is their fate
one after another
[Music]
[Music]
i have one more award to give out
tonight and that is best sony
playstation game
so without further ado the winner
is cyberpunk 2077 congratulations
of course there are even more awards
than the ones i announced tonight
so check out the gamescom awards user
voting where you can vote for your
favorite streamer
gamescom's most wanted and best of
gamescom
the winners will be revealed at gamescom
best of show along with cool cosplayers
esports and more
so tune in on sunday august 30th at 8pm
central european time
to see the grand finale of this year's
gamescom where we give gamers the stage
that's it for me tonight but before i
turn it back to jeff i just want to say
that i hope
everyone out there is staying safe and
healthy we're all in this together so
take care back to you jeff
thank you very much uh sydney and it's
great to have you on the show again
this year uh all right well a lot of
people have been wondering
what will the next generation of gaming
feel like how will it be different
what is that generational difference
well
back in june we saw the announcement of
ratchet and clank rift apart from
insomniac games
a title which uses the power of
playstation 5
the ssd hard drive and the dual sense
controller to create an experience that
insomniac says
is only possible on brand new hardware
well
now it's time for you to decide if you
see the difference here's an
extended uninterrupted demo of live
playstation 5 gameplay
of ratchet and clank rift apart enjoy
trump
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and not far from where we last saw him
we may still have time to put a stop to
this
hey i think i found them on that oh
bringing out the big guns
[Music]
feels good to be back in action
last one
the train's pulling away let's go
[Applause]
is
soon everything you see will
be mine
say goodbye
what did
was that supposed to happen hitting
nefarious device seems to have
destabilized reality
the bridge is shot there has to be
another way across
[Applause]
hmm the rips appeared to react to your
device
try pointing it at one of them
that was rather
oh
this is worse than i had imagined
it's ratchet and clank
sand sharks from above
my heroes
i knew you'd come
or at least a very large octopus
i will never get used to that hey at
least we're on the same planet this time
nefarious is on the other side of that
building let's get moving before he does
anything else to break reality
again yeah i kind of wish he was doing a
worse job
he must have more planned than he is
telling us
that's what i'm afraid of
wow
can't wait to see what's new
more butts
that's all of them we have to get the
dimensionator away from nefarious
the dimensions are weakening
[Music]
considerably
[Music]
well it is certainly not good
uh
[Music]
oh
ratchet we are too late
ratchet
[Music]
whoa
there you have it ratchet and clank rift
apart and now i am joined by marcus
smith and mike daly from insomniac games
uh guys it was so great to see that uh
long uninterrupted demo of uh rift apart
and i have so many questions uh it's
amazing to see what you're doing with
the power of ps5 and the ssd um
let me ask you first marcus what are you
able to do with rift apart that you
haven't been able to do before in a
ratchet game because of the power of ps5
i mean first and foremost it's just pure
horsepower enables us to fill
our worlds with the kind of density and
life that we've never been able to do
before
more importantly perhaps though is the
dimensional shifting that we have going
on
which uses the ssd uh that allows us to
fling the player
from planet to planet to planet uh
lightning fast like in
way way faster than we've ever been able
to do before
yeah the the rift tether we saw that in
the uh demo we had seen some of that in
the
the trailer so that's that's all actual
i'm curious how does that how does that
work as you kind of play through the
game are there certain moments and
levels where you can jump or how do you
play through that
yeah so in the game there is dimensional
damage spread throughout the galaxy that
ratchet and clank have to find a way to
fix
and you can find these weak points in
space-time
that you can pull to you with your rift
tether
it's like being able to lasso a portal
and that enables you to basically like
warp across the world
to find new places to discover or gain a
tactical advantage in combat
wow yeah i gotta say like when you see
that and you imagine the jumping from
multiple worlds
uh at you know at instantaneously almost
and it sounds like there's no load
screens throughout the entire game
that's right we're going straight that's
right yep wow all right
so confident both of you say it i like
it um now
let me ask you about dual sense that's
something that is a big part of ps5
i've had a chance to control with the
triggers and the haptics
um how are you using that for to sort of
impact the gameplay of rift apart
so every ratchet and clank game is a
powerful arsenal
of weapons just exude a ton of
personality
and the dual sense is sort of like it
feels like it was made
for ratchet and clank just because the
haptics give us a whole new layer for
the weapons to express
themselves so for example your burst
pistol
of course it gives you like a satisfying
click or kick with every bullet
but when you throw the shatter bomb you
can actually feel the energy pulsing off
the grenade
fade away as it gets further apart from
you basically
the haptics are expressive enough that
every weapon feels different and you can
tell what you're holding
but of course the adaptive trigger like
takes that to a functional level
where in addition to the trigger pull
feeling unique
we can actually use that as a super
intuitive way
to add alternate functions to the
weapons so
for example in the demo we've got the
enforcer which is a double-barreled
shotgun
you can pull the trigger part of the way
down until you hit resistance
to fire a single barrel and then
whenever you feel like it's the right
time pull it the rest of the way for a
double shot
so you might be swarmed by a bunch of
little enemies you only want to
waste one shot on them and then wait a
minute for even more to swarm in before
finishing
them off but a big guy you probably want
to just give both barrels to you right
away
so there's a nice intuitive way of
basically raising the skill ceiling
and giving you more ways to play better
wow no i'm
excited to see how you guys are gonna
roll that out across what i'm sure are
an insane uh you know group of weapons
as always uh
plot wise marcus tell us a bit about
this game i think some fans have
wondered you know does this tie into the
movie plot line the game plot line like
how it would tell us in the ratchet
verse where this sits
yeah well canonically this is a an
extension of
uh ratchet and clank into the nexus the
2013 game
but it's a standalone adventure so it's
one that
even if you've never played a ratchet
and clan game you can get into it and
you'll understand it and you'll enjoy it
um for hardcore fans we have a lot of
nods you're gonna
you're gonna see a lot of returning
characters and planets and
uh see them all through a whole new
light of multiple dimensionality
yeah no this this rift tether thing i
think looks really exciting and how
often
like is that something we saw in the
demo is that something you're going to
see like frequently in the game are
there special moments like i guess i'm
curious like how
often you use that technique for play
so the the rift tether has created
these anomalies all throughout the
galaxy you'll encounter those pretty
often
there's even a few more types of
dimensional damage you'll encounter that
we haven't shown yet
now being pulled between worlds that's
that's localized to
chasing after dr nefarious in the demo
um and that's sort of reserved for
special moments when you really have to
um when the dimensional damage really
tears wide open
well i gotta say it looks incredible and
then at the end
we got another tease of uh this female
lombax uh i know you guys are confirmed
she is playable
in parts of the game i think everyone
wants to know though do we have a name
for her
uh i mean the world is more interesting
with mysteries and we're gonna have to
keep this one
uh a little longer do we get a number of
letters in her name or anything
too many smart people on the internet
okay they'll figure it out right away
she's not named abby though right
all right we'll have to wait and see
what you guys have in store for us
i gotta say i mean it looks incredible
the ratchet games are always so much fun
and as you said when you think of
the power of ssd and the dual sense all
coming together uh it looks really
exciting
before we go though uh i think everyone
around the world
wants to know when we're going to get to
play this game
anything you can share with us on where
you're at in development right now
mike mike
sir ratchet and clank is coming out in
the ps5
launch window so we haven't announced to
release a specific release date yet so
stay tuned for that
what kind of window is it big window so
no i'm just kidding all right that's all
we're gonna get i'm sure
ratchet and clank ripped apart coming in
the launch window for playstation 5. i
got to say uh
insomniac uh we're so excited you guys
are doing across playstation
and the game looks incredible so thank
you so much for
all you've done and we look forward to
seeing more of riff to part soon
thanks jeff take care all right marcus
and mike from insomniac
thanks for showing us that first look at
ratchet and clank or playstation live
and that's going to do it
for opening night live thank you so much
for watching from around the world
and make sure to stay tuned all weekend
for more
live gamescom coverage at
gamescom.global as for us we'll see you
later this year for the game awards 2020
our team is hard at work to build a very
special live show for you
coming in december we'll see you then
good night
[Music]
you